[Music]
you watch a lot of uh American
Cinema well you have a wonderful podcast
that I've been on many times that I've
you know some would say ruined many
times yeah that's I hope people listen
to Doug Love's movies the episode that
you were on well in general in general
yes but also the ones that you've been
on yeah if they're if they become a fan
of you on this show yes so that they
could see the other Pete yeah that I
know and don't like
you know what I mean Rowdy be the one
that doesn't let anyone else speak on
your show there's a give and take yep on
my podcast you just go off you know
that's something I think about a lot is
that there are different sides to
different people you know what I mean
and when I go on your show it's almost
like a ritual I'm like I'm going to be
the Doug Loves Movies Pete you know what
I mean it's like uh how Eminem has
different personas but who is that Pete
like who is that guy supposed to be cuz
he's
terrible let me tell you something while
I agree with you if I could like touch
your forehead like your third eye and
transport you into the body of Doug
Loves Pete ruin like do Doug Loves
Movies ruining Pete you'd have the time
of your
life it's a it's a gift you give
me dou that's some trippy
well how how you also have another
podcast dining with Doug and Karen I
have podcasts for all of my loves y for
you know marijuana and for for movies
and for food the trilogy because you get
them for free when you have a podcast
about them what do you mean people give
me weed people people let me into movies
or send me their movies and people uh
chefs on dining with Doug and Karen come
on and they cook us a nice meal yeah and
and we just get to eat it and talk about
it I don't even know anything about food
Pete but the food podcast is a great
place I found for my guests to meet
people to go out
with like you for
instance that one time I did go out with
a girl did go out with a the chef I went
out with the chef on the show so to get
even with you you son of a I'm I
sealed the deal tonight I'm going out
with your makeup
[Laughter]
artist
and and by sealed the deal by seal the
deal I mean she doesn't know this yet of
course this is how she's finding out the
classiest most Surefire way to ask
somebody out ever is to do it during
this interview
[Music]
mhm